i didn't start sbtv to make money i
started sbtv because it was a passion he
was the man who helped launch the
careers of some of british music's
biggest names through an online platform
that began life as a youtube channel
when jamal edwards was just
15. they say she's in the class 18.
ed sheeran is among a long line of stars
whose songs were first profiled on sbtv
this was in 2010 i've been trying to get
my mummy yard feeling like i can't
breathe life is south london's heart the
rapper dave another who first came to
prominence thanks to the enterprise of
edwards the main reason for me setting
sbtv up was because i didn't feel like
my mates were being put
on a
on a mainstream platform so i thought i
wanted to create a platform for them to
be able to express their views and
opinions
the platform catapulted the grime music
of london onto a global stage
to harness the power of the new media
landscape
edwards was made an mbe for services to
music in 2014 and became an ambassador
for the prince of wales's charity the
prince's trust helping young people to
set up their own companies
among the numerous tributes on twitter
the rapper aj tracy tweeted r.i.p jamal
edwards west london legend status while
lady lisha said i'm in tears so
heartbreaking to hear the news of jamal
edwards and the organisers of the moba
awards said as the founder of sbtv
online his groundbreaking work and
legacy in british music and culture will
live on
a pioneer who changed the landscape of
both music and media either bennett sky
news
well in the last hour the family of
jamal edwards has released a statement
his mum brenda
who you may know as a panelist on loose
women wrote on the show's twitter
account
it is with
deepest heartache that i confirm that my
beautiful son jamal passed away
yesterday morning after a sudden illness
myself his sister tanisha and the rest
of his family and friends are completely
devastated he was the center
of our world